Gulch, gulf, gull, gullibility- Oh it is here!
JULES!
Hey, everybody, Julian here for DNews.
Pop quiz: Can you remember how many animals
of each kind Moses took onto the ark?
If your answer is two, think again.
The correct answer is… zero.
Moses didn’t actually take any animals onto
the ark, Noah did.
If you didn’t catch the error, don’t worry,
you’re far from the first to miss it.
In fact, a recent study in Psychology Press
notes that failing to register errors in questions
like this happens all the time.
In the study, participants were asked questions
that were both “distorted” with false
information, like the Moses example, and questions
that had no false information.
The participants answered 35% of distorted
questions as if they were correct, even after
they were told to watch out for false information.
But most of us do know that Noah was the one
who brought animals aboard the ark.
So then why isn’t this prior knowledge enough
to detect the error?
The study calls this phenomenon “knowledge
neglect,” which means that prior knowledge
about a topic doesn’t save us from falling
for semantic errors.
Some have likened this to absentmindedness.
Others may simply see it as being gullible
-- easily duped or cheated.
The study also found that not only do people
often miss semantic errors like this, but
they also use the false information to answer
general questions later on.
For example: if someone reads a statement
that incorrectly refers to a prune as a dried
date instead of a dried plum, that person
is more likely to think that prunes are dates
later on when they’re asked about it.
In fact, we’re prone to accepting entirely
erroneous stories as truth, which can cause
us to believe in conspiracies, major myths
and fake news.
So, if we’re an intelligent bunch here (which
we are), why is it that we’re prone to fall
for myths about vaccines causing autism and
the earth being flat?
Just because we’re gullible doesn’t mean
we’re stupid...right?
Exactly.
Multiple factors encourage gullibility.
Images for instance, play a powerful role
in giving credibility to messages.
Studies found that pairing claims with photographs
increased the believability of a claim whether
it was true or not.
We’re also more likely to believe information
if it’s told to us by someone we’re acquainted
with... even if that someone is a talking
head on a news program who we don’t personally
know, but have grown familiar with simply
by repeated exposure.
Similar to how we grow familiar with a person,
we also grow familiar with a message.
Studies found that the more we see or hear
a certain message and the more consistently
that message aligns with our beliefs, the
more inclined we are to believe it.
Imagine having a bias against a certain person,
and then reading a headline condemning that
person for committing a crime.
Whether it’s true or not, our mind already
recognizes that the message is both familiar
and consistent with previous thoughts, and
suddenly we’re one step closer to believing
it.
This tendency to interpret evidence in ways
that confirm our beliefs is known as confirmation
bias.
These factors allow our minds to do less work
and take mental short cuts when processing.
So, if you or someone you know has fallen
into a gullibility trap, how do you get out
of it?
It’s not that easy.
Because misinformation gets embedded in our
memory, retracting it is difficult as it would
leave gaps in a truth we’ve come to believe.
We have to do more than focus on the right
facts.
When we bring up the false information to
debunk the myth, we’re also providing another
opportunity for someone to become more familiar
with it and develop an even deeper conviction
for the misinformation.
Instead of trying to compare misinformation
to the real story, we should focus solely
on the truth, using clear language and pictures
in the explanation, so it’s easier to process.
Now that you know more about gullibility tricky
ways, consider yourself armed for the next
time you enter the arena of news headlines
and storytelling.
Speaking of myths...how about clean coal?
We have a video about why that might not be
a real thing, here.
And be sure to visit our friends at Seeker
Stories!
They’ve got a new video on the power of
Chile’s student resistance movement here.
So, did you fall for the Moses on the ark bit?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe for more,
and I'll see you next time on DNews.